hello everyone welcome to this video on
what is ml Ops by simply learn and let
me tell you guys that we have regular
updates on multiple Technologies if you
are a tech geek in a continuous hunt for
the latest technological Trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
YouTube channel and press that Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn in this video first we will see
what amylops is after that we will cover
the use of mlops after that we will see
some real world application of envelopes
after that we will see components of
envelopes at the end we will see
difference between mlops and devops by
the end of this video I can assure you
that all your questions and doubts
related to what is mlops will have been
clear on that note if you are an
aspiring AIML engineer then there is no
better time to train yourself in the
exciting field of machine learning if
you are looking for course that covers
everything from the fundamentals to
Advanced Techniques like machine
learning algorithm development and
unsupervised learning look no further
than our Caltech program in partnership
with IBM this AIML program bootcamp is
collaboration with Caltech will help you
advance your career as an AI ml
specialist the AIML bootcamp includes
live classes delivered by industry
expert Hands-On likes industry relevant
projects and master classes by Caltech
professors key feature of this amazing
course includes earn up to 22 CEOs from
Caltech ctme online convocation by
Caltech ctme program director simply
learned Career Services help you get
noticed by top hiring companies earn a
bootcamp Caltech certificate industry
relevant Capstone project in three
domains Caltech ctm is circle membership
25 plus Hands-On project across
Industries verticals with integrated
Labs so why wait join now seats are
feeling fast find the course link from
the description box below so moving
forward let's see what is mlops mL of
short for machine learning operation is
a set of practices tools and principles
that aim to streamline and enhance the
deploy appointment management and
monitoring of machine learning models in
production of environments it draws
inspiration from devops development and
operation practices and applies them
specifically to the challenges of
deploying and maintaining ml model
effectively moving forward let's see
what is the use of mlops mloff serves
crucial purposes in the context of
deploying and managing ml models in
production environment the first one is
efficient development mlops helps
automate the deployment process of
machine learning models making it faster
reputable and less error prone this
enables the organization to quickly
transition from development to
production reducing the time it takes to
make model available to end user the
second one is collaboration mlops
encourages collaboration between
different teams such as data scientists
machine learning engineer operation and
business stakeholder by frosting better
communication and Alignment mlops helps
deliver solution that meets Technical
and business requirement the third one
is monitoring and in it mlos provides
tools for monitoring the performance of
deployed models in real world condition
this allows teams to detect anomalies
track key performance metrics and
address issue promptly ensuring that the
models continue to deliver accurate
result over time the fourth one is cost
efficiency by optimizing resource
utilization and automatic process mlops
can lead to cost saving efficiently
managed deployment reduce operational
overhead and resource wasted making
machine learning project more
economically viable the fifth one is
Security in many Industries compliance
and security are Paramount concern mlr
provides practices for managing access
controls data privacy and regular
environment ensuring deployed model
adhere to necessary standard so in
summary amylops plays a critical role in
maximizing the value of machine learning
by ensuring that models are efficiently
deployed monitored maintained and
improved in production environments it
enables organization to drive consistent
reliable and scalable benefits from
their machine learning investment moving
forward let's see some real world
application of mlops so mlos find
application in various areas where
machine learning models are deployed in
real world production environment some
typical application of ml Ops include
the first one is Predictive Analytics
mlops helps deploy Predictive Analytics
that analyze historical data to predict
future events these models are used in
finance market sales and other
Industries to forecast Trends and
optimize decision making the second one
is image video analysis ml Ops is used
to application like image classification
object detection and facial recognition
these Technologies are employed in
security system autonomous vehicles and
Medical Imaging the third one is
Healthcare and Medical Diagnostic mlops
AIDS in development and deploying models
for medical imaging analysis disease
diagnosis drug Discovery and patient
risk assessment the fourth one is
autonomous system amylops is crucial for
autonomous systems like vehicle drones
and Robotics ensuring that AI model
function is liable and adapt to changing
condition so these are some just a few
example of mlo and the application of
mlops are continuously expanding as
organization explore new ways to
leverage machine learning in their
operation so accelerate your career in
AIM with Comprehensive postgraduate
program in AIML machine learning boost
your careers with this AIML course
delivered in collaboration with party
University and IBM learn in demand
skills such as machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative by
prompt engineering chat gbt and many
more you will receive a prestigious
certificate and ask me anything session
by IBM with five caps shown in different
domains using real data set you will
gain practical experience master classes
are party University and Purdue faculty
and IBM experts ensure top-notch
education simply run job assist help you
get noticed by Leading companies so why
we're join now seats are failing fast
course link is in the description box
below and in the pinned comment moving
forward let's see component of envelopes
the extent of ml Ops in machine learning
project can vary based on the project
needs sometimes ml Ops covers everything
from preparing the data to making the
final model other times it might just
involve putting the model into action
most companies use mlops for the first
one is exploded data analysis looking
into the data to understand it the
second one is getting the data ready and
making valuable features from it data
preparation and feature engineering the
third one is model training and the fine
tuning the fourth one is model review
and the governance fifth one is model
inference and serving model six one is
model deployment and monitoring the last
one is teaching the model again
automatically when needed moving forward
let's see some difference between
amylopes and devops the first one is
mlops specifically focus on the
deployment monitoring and management of
machine learning model while devops
devops Family Focus on the collaboration
and integration between development and
operation the second one is it is
centered around machine learning AI
application addressing the unique
challenges of deploying and maintaining
models while in devops it applies to
software development in in general
covering all aspects of software
engineering and deployment the third one
is mlops involves automating the
end-to-end machine learning lifecycle
from data pre-processing to data model
monitoring and retraining here while
devops aims to streamline the deployment
lifecycle automate deployment pipelines
improve collaboration and ensure faster
and more Reliable Software releases and
the fourth one is mlops employs tools
for model versioning model packaging
model monitoring automated returning and
model explanation while devops employs
tools like Version Control Systems like
git continuous integration containers
deployment cicd pipelines configuration
management and infrastructure as code to
achieve its score the last one is
efficient model deployment continuous
model performance monitoring
reproductively collaboration between
data scientists and engineers and
adapting to changing data and
requirements here the faster development
Cycles continuous integration quick and
automated deployment improve team
collaboration and increase software
reliability
in somebody
while devops and mL of share concept of
automation collaboration and continuous
Improvement devops has a broader focus
on software development and deployment
while ml Ops is tailors to change the
challenges specific or to deployment and
managing machine learning models in
production setting both practices aims
to enhance efficiency collaboration and
reliability in their respective domains
and with that we have come to end of
this video on what is mlops I hope you
found it valuable and entertaining
please ask any question about the topics
covered in this video in the comment box
below what experts will assist you in
addressing your problem thank you for
watching stay safe and keep learning
with simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here